[MUSIC PLAYING]
MAGGIE JACKSON:
Well, good morning
and welcome to Building Healthy
Technology, an inspiration
session on digital well-being.
I'm Maggie Jackson.
I'm the author of
"Distracted," a book
about the fragmentation of focus
and the ways we can recapture
our attention today.
I'm a journalist-- my background
and a former "Boston Globe"
columnist.
And joining me on my
left is Adam Alter.
He is a NYU professor in
marketing and psychology,
and writes widely for the media,
and has written most recently
a book called "Irresistible,"
about behavioral addiction
in our society and
tech influences.
As well, joining me on
the stage is Glen Murphy.
He's the director of UX Chrome.
And he has been a creative force
behind many Android products
from Android Auto and TV,
and behind a creative force
in the digital well-being
front, of which you've
heard quite a bit this week.
So we'll talk about that.
And I'd also like to thank
Helen Hutton and Nancy Baker
for putting this
together so well.
Just for a minute, let's start
by stepping back in history,
stepping back in time.
The year is 1905
and picture Freud.
Yes, Freud standing on
the Piazza Colonna in Rome
on a warm September evening.
He's watching a
lantern slide show.
And it's a medley of short
films and still photographs
projected on the roofs of
the houses in the Piazza.
And as he writes later, every
time he tries to turn away,
a certain tension in the
crowd keeps him riveted.
This great thinker
far from home was
entranced by the media,
the precursors of the media
that envelop us today.
He was conflicted,
and so are we.
Fast-forward to our
century and we're
wrestling, still, with the
promise and the drawbacks
of technology.
So today, we're going to
talk a little bit about some
of the challenges,
some of the ways
in which we can
harness the benefits,
and also, begin to take more
responsibility-- all of us
as makers, developers,
citizens, and parents
for what we're creating.
So to start, of course,
it's really important
to understand the
landscape, understand
what we're experiencing.
So, Adam, maybe
we'll start with you
to talk a little bit about
the history of technology.
And for millennia, people
have been associating
new technologies with
something fearful,
something challenging,
ever since Plato
complained that the
written word would
undermine our memories that were
so important in oral culture.
So how serious are the
problems of our time?
Why should we be
paying attention?
ADAM ALTER: Well, I mean, if
you think about human evolution,
things that are novel
are obviously very scary,
because we haven't
yet tested them out.
We don't know if they're
there to help us, or hurt us,
or if they're neutral.
And so any time something
new comes along,
there's an instinctive
panic in some sense.
And that's where
we are here again.
And we've had that
all through time.
In the 20th century, it was
TV, and pinball machines,
and video games, and all
sorts of other things.
And one of the questions
people ask all the time,
I think quite validly
is, is this different?
Are we talking about
something different
now in the last 10, 15 years?
Or is this just the
latest moral panic
that we're all dealing with?
I think there are some things
that make this different.
I think for sheer scope, we're
talking about experiences
that billions of us
enjoy, or sometimes don't
enjoy the hours, and hours,
and hours of the day.
So the average American adult
spends four hours every day
glued to a phone
screen, so that's
taking up a huge amount
of the waking day.
So we should understand
that, I think, quite well.
Another thing that's
different, I think,
is that if you think about
these past technologies,
we've left most of them at home.
So even if you
watched a lot of TV,
that was bound to
a particular place.
But now, we wear our devices.
And so if you ask
people-- if you ask,
again, adults in the developed
world, how much time do you
spend with your phones?
75% of adults will say
that 24 hours a day they
can reach their
phones without having
to move their feet, which
is not hugely surprising.
But again, it suggests
there's something a bit
different about what
we're experiencing now.
It's not the pinball
machine at the arcade.
It's the phone that's
actually almost a part of you.
It's an extension of you.
So I think there are
a number of features
that make this different.
We're also much more
sophisticated in developing
technologies than we ever were.
We understand human
psychology better.
As a psychologist
who's consulted
on a number of these projects,
I know how much we know,
how much we understand
about what drives humans.
So I think there are
some features that
make this a bit
different from what
we've experienced in the past.
MAGGIE JACKSON: Right.
The degree of
penetration, the fact
that we're inhabiting
this in our--
it's total as well
as the rapid change.
I think that's a
really important point.
So, Glen, in order to come out
with all of the new changes,
you have to keep your
finger on the pulse.
And tell us a little
bit about the research
that, for instance, has
gone into the announcements
this week related to
digital well-being.
Are people feeling helpless in
their devices, or empowered,
or both?
GLEN MURPHY: Yeah.
So it's a really
exciting time for us
You probably saw
Sundar the other day
talk about fear of missing out
and the joy of missing out.
The joy of missing out--
the title of the research
that we had done,
and it was really interesting.
We went out and we saw how
people engaged with technology
in the world.
And we saw many of the
things that we see,
which is sort of once your
head is down in the phone,
it's very easy to
sort of stay there.
There are many things, many
exciting things in there
that keep you in there.
But I think the
other part that we
saw that was really
interesting was just
how social factors became
a large part of this.
Unlike TV or even
desktop computing,
which would generally--
relatively solitary things--
a phone is an inherently
social object.
And so one of the key
things that we saw
was that even if
there was nothing
for you to do on your phone,
you still kept it nearby,
because there were other people
who were trying to reach you.
And so we all became part
of this big mesh of humans
contacting each other.
And I think that was something
that we had underestimated
in all of this-- the role
of each other in this area.
So, yeah, it's really exciting.
MAGGIE JACKSON: And I think--
well, actually, when cell
phones first came out,
I used to joke that
people should--
who are buying them--
maybe you haven't
heard of RadioShack.
But we used to buy phones
at RadioShack that people--
the guy at the store
should take you in the back
and give you counseling,
just like the minister
might when you get married.
Here's what you need to know.
So I think, yeah,
that's really important.
And what about the
emotional factors
related to these feedback loops?
Can you just elaborate
a little bit about--
because I know it's
really complex,
and we are right in
the middle of it.
And it reminds me also of books.
When you're reading
a book, the content
is where your attention lies.
But there is a technology
around it that affects you.
It's a lot less static
than people think.
So what are we not
aware of in terms
of our emotional responses?
And were you surprised
at the myriad responses
that people had?
GLEN MURPHY: Yeah.
This whole space is
really interesting,
because there are some deeply
individual responses in here.
I think it's really hard to
draw broad generalizations,
but the feedback thing, I
think, is really interesting.
Adam talks a lot about
this-- actually in your book
about how we use these
devices, and they
are immensely useful to us.
They've replaced maps.
They've replaced clocks.
They've replaced
writing letters.
all these things.
And you do those actions,
and you feel good.
They're performing an
essential utility in your life.
But then it's sort of very
easy for those interactions
to then bleed into
other behaviors that
are maybe less useful, or
maybe they're entertaining.
And then you can
kind of keep going,
because there is this
feedback loop of like,
oh, just one more thing.
And so that's why we think
about how a lot of that
is very invisible to the user.
I think you've talked
elsewhere about how
sometimes our own
use of technology
can be very invisible to us.
And so a key thing for us is
how we can provide awareness
to people.
I don't think it's a total
number of hours thing--
or that's a good indicator.
It's how you felt
about that time.
And I think, often we
find when we show people
how much they were
actually engaging,
they're often surprised.
And I think that's a really
interesting component.
MAGGIE JACKSON: Yeah,
a reflective component.
ADAM ALTER: It's
also interesting.
There are sort of scripts
that different people follow.
I know I have one.
When I open my phone, there's
a certain set of apps.
And I'll go in this loop,
back to the same one again,
and then I'll start.
I'll go through five or
six of them and go back.
And if there's
something, you get
into a sort of lulled sense
of calm when you do that.
And that's, I think,
a really big part
of driving you to keep
engaging over and over again.
MAGGIE JACKSON: Yeah.
I think backstage
we were talking
about the automaticity
of the human being
as being such a crucial
factor in everything we do.
It underlays expertise.
We have to do things without
really thinking about them.
On the other hand,
we have to be aware.
We evolve to be as reflective
as we did to be automatic,
and that's really important.
So we're kind of
learning as we go, and we
have these conflicted senses.
And I think we don't have
the option to get it wrong.
Honestly, I think we need to
have technology and humanity
come together in better ways
to make us more compassionate,
better discerning thinkers.
So let's turn to the
crucial first steps.
Again, Glen, maybe
you can kick it off
by talking about the
Android announcements.
And I thought it was interesting
that some keywords that you
had mentioned in our
preliminary talks
were control and awareness.
You mentioned awareness.
But how are some of the
wind down and shush going
to give people more control?
And do you have a sense that,
how effective will this be?
Or is it a question mark?
GLEN MURPHY: Yeah.
So the Android announcements
that we announced the other day
were oriented around
awareness and control,
giving people visibility into
what they're actually doing.
So they can be aware
of what's happening.
And then giving
them the tools to be
able to change that
behavior if they so choose.
And I think it's
really been interesting
for us as we've approached
this space and thinking
about the right ways to handle
the responsibility that we
have.
In some ways, we have
been thinking about,
where should that
regulation lie?
Should it be
technologically regulated?
And we sort of came down to--
many of these things start
with self-regulation.
I think in many ways
that feeling of control
is really important to people.
And so we haven't provided that
in the platform historically.
There's little bits
here and there.
But we want to take that
further and to give people
that feeling of
awareness and control,
so that as people are having
these feelings about using
their phones, they
have the ability
to change how they're using it.
And to your question about
whether all of these things
will work, I think this
is an ongoing thing.
We were talking backstage
about how many of the things
that we all use in our
life, like to-do lists
and other things.
Often they are effective
for some amount of time,
and then we kind of
adapt, and then we sort of
find other ways to do things.
And so I expect this to be a
long-running effort for us.
As we learn, it might
be that we encounter
sort of different cultures
that have different attitudes
towards the phone.
And how we deal with that
is really interesting.
Even going back to the
pre-smartphone era,
we found that there
were many places where
the attitude to dealing
with a ringing phone
was very different.
In some places, you
always have to answer it,
regardless of what you
were doing, and others--
it was OK to let it ring out.
And so that sort
of responsibility
of respecting the cultural
norms and helping people
think about those cultural
norms is sort of where we're at.
MAGGIE JACKSON: Yeah.
Well, I used to think
about attention,
which is a multi-faceted--
scientists used
to ask me, when I
was first studying attention,
the trick question of,
what kind of
attention do you mean?
Because it's a messy, big thing.
But I used to think of it--
I think of it now as
arrows in one's quiver.
You can use focus.
You can use awareness.
You can use executive attention.
But they're tools just
as perhaps these tools.
And I think that
your announcements
are a very, very, big deal.
I do have to say that--
I mean, the mantra or the
overarching societal push
has been towards seamlessness.
I mean, that's been
an unbroken thing.
You must engage, or it's
beneficial to engage.
To break that at all
is really momentous.
And I think that that's
a huge step forward.
As a very critical
person about technology,
I think it's a big step forward.
GLEN MURPHY: I think--
sorry, just on that.
I think it is really something
that's interesting for everyone
here who is a developer to
think about-- is that we
have been focused on
immediacy and seamlessness
for a long time.
We clearly know that
that's a key aspect
to sort of empowering people.
But thinking about that
in a social context,
creating something that is
immediate for you as a sender
also creates something on the
other side for the receiver.
And so as we've developed
all of these things that
are very immediate, there is
another side of the equation
that we've got to think about.
MAGGIE JACKSON: Yeah.
And I think that's important.
Go ahead.
ADAM ALTER: Yeah.
No, I totally agree with that.
I think there's always
going to be this sort of--
not the backlash, but
the other side of that,
that the quicker the transfer
becomes in the one direction,
the quicker you'll
expect to get the reply.
GLEN MURPHY: That's right.
ADAM ALTER: It's a
really interesting idea.
And also, this general idea of
the role of frictionlessness
and the absence of pain points.
We talk about this all
the time in business.
I'm a professor in
a business school.
And one of the
mantras in business
is make everything as
simple as possible.
One of the best ways
to spend your money
is to remove pain points,
so friction points.
And that makes total
sense, because that's
the best way to ensure not just
engagement for five minutes,
but for sometimes weeks,
years, even decades.
And I think we've now
pushed that to a point where
we're starting to get the
initial backlash, and that's--
it's great that
these new introduced
tools allow people to manage
that a little bit, to introduce
frictions where they
might be valuable.
GLEN MURPHY: That's right.
MAGGIE JACKSON: Yeah.
And I also think that
it's really important
to think about the idea
of disconnection, which
might be a change in
the tempo or the rhythm
that allows you
to gain friction,
but to think about that
in a way that's not just
in an on and off way.
So in other words, maybe
we can open up the space
to these questions, so
we're not just thinking
about the little pause points
as being away from technology,
but importing that discussion
into the very digital space.
And I think about that
currently in relation
to the idea of technology--
I mean, I'm sorry, in relation
to the idea of uncertainty.
Uncertainty seems like
a very negative thing,
but just consider one of
the unintended consequences
of having answers at your
fingertips all the time--
this instantaneity,
which actually came in,
in the 17th, 18th, 19th century.
I mean, this has just
been rolling along
for hundreds of years.
Efficiency is it.
But now, there are
studies that are showing
a little bit of
hints here and there
about what it means to have
that instantaneity all the time.
For instance, after
briefly searching online,
people are seen to be
less willing to solve--
to tackle a complex
problem later.
After briefly
searching online, they
become a little bit
more confident--
overconfident, I mean,
about what they know.
They don't really know what
they know and don't know.
And I think these are really
important hints, because--
and why does this matter?
I think it matters
because there is
that side of ourselves that's
automatic-- the quick mind,
thrives in the routine,
needs instant answers,
does really well
in the familiar.
But then if we exist on
a steady diet of the meat
in the package, then the
downloadable and the instant
all the time, we're
beginning to possibly forget
to tap into the other
side of ourselves--
the reflective, the
questioning, the skeptical,
the so-called slow mind.
And in fact, there's a
really exciting new explosion
of research into various forms
of uncertainty as actually
connected to good thinking.
For instance-- and this
really does, I think,
connect to technology
and well-being.
But ambivalence in
CEOs in a crisis
is shown to induce them
to do deeper research,
to look at multiple
perspectives,
to include more voices, and
then to take bolder action.
Wow.
And then confusion in students--
again, people have always
thought the easy lesson--
that what's good, easy to
digest is better for learning.
But it's shown in
complex situations
that confusion relates--
leads to deeper
processing in students.
So these sort of factors
fly against a lot
of what our society values.
And I think that, why not
develop a digital world where
the human is more inspired
to say, oh, I don't know?
Or to pause and then jack into
that kind of discerning self
that they have.
And I'll just leave this
point with one other piece
of research, which is that when
people in the United States
are surveyed and asked, what's
positive about technology?
60% say speed, instant access
to information, convenience.
But just 10% say a
positive about technology
is that it promotes knowledge,
understanding, and curiosity.
So that's a really
big disconnect.
And if we could propel our
other side of ourselves
into that space with
developers' help,
I think that would
be really powerful.
And it has everything to do with
all the hardship, et cetera.
ADAM ALTER: Right.
Yeah.
If you think about the
way we stored information,
say, in the early '80s
when I was growing up,
I probably knew 100
phone numbers by heart,
and that seemed straightforward.
And I think all kids
at that time did.
They knew the-- you
knew your friend's.
You knew your family
members' phone numbers.
You knew some other ones.
And what that did was it meant
that certain memory faculties
were always being used,
and they were being trained
without your even realizing it.
And there's a lot of
research now extending
what you're suggesting
into a concept known
as hardship inoculation.
And it's the idea that if you
use your mind in certain ways,
if you think about things in
certain ways in small doses,
you become much better
prepared to deal
with major tackles, major
problems, major creativity
hurdles.
Times when the way you've
been thinking about things
in a traditional
sense are not going
to work-- how do
you get around that?
Turns out, having those
100 numbers in your head,
training your memory--
that also applies to how we
use our minds in other ways.
And so when everything
is absolutely seamless
and we don't have
to memorize, we
don't have to try to think about
what we're going to do next.
Because we have a
device that's going
to deliver entertainment
in the next three seconds
if that's what we want.
I think those faculties
wither away a little bit.
And so it's important to have
occasions when we do use them,
even in a low-grade sense, just
so that they're kept alive.
It's like a muscle
that's withering away.
So you want to
make sure that life
isn't so straightforward and
seamless that we're always
our automatic selves and
never our reflective selves.
GLEN MURPHY: That reminds
me a lot of the discussions
about discipline and how that
sort of leads to developments
later in people's lives.
But I think a key
takeaway for me
is thinking about how technology
in many ways can be used to--
I think the ideal is-- and
in many ways it's true.
It helps us become more
active in other areas.
As we make some
things easier, that
allows us to devote
time and attention
to the things that matter.
And I think the danger is that--
where we don't elevate
ourselves in that way.
And we can end up
becoming purely passive.
There's plenty of time.
There are times for
that in people's lives.
I was in-- hospital
for a week once.
And I was very passive
for the entire--
and we can end up
becoming [AUDIO OUT]..
MAGGIE JACKSON: So I
think we're exploring
how to get a grip
on this landscape.
We're also talking about
well-being, which is a very--
also, messy, ill-defined topic.
But we've talked about control.
We're talking about awareness.
We're talking about
hardship and uncertainty.
I mean, these motifs
or notions plug
into psychological ideas about
well-being, mastery, control,
accomplishment as well as social
relationships, and health.
Those are really
important components.
I mean, what would you
think digital well-being--
what would it look like if the
United Nations in five years
was--
or this-- the kingdom of Bhutan
came out with the new GDP
for digital--
well, DWB?
We can all scale mountains there
and see what it feels like.
But what do you think it
should look like, Glen?
GLEN MURPHY: Yeah.
That's a super deep question.
I do think that there
may not be a global view.
There may not be--
MAGGIE JACKSON:
That's a good point.
GLEN MURPHY: --a
country-wide view.
And I think that the thing we
grapple with is, at what level
is there a shared view?
Is it even at the
friends' level?
Is it at the family level?
Is it different within
different social contexts?
We talk about use of technology.
And it can mean--
the exact same usage
can mean different things
to different people.
It can lead to a different
sense of satisfaction.
I think there are key metrics
about whether people feel
that their use of technology
was overall beneficial to them,
whether they derived
value from it.
And I think it's--
there's a lot of debate about
what that value should be.
I think we all impose our
own values upon the world
as we think through
these things.
And I think it is--
for some people, the value
is you produced something
for others.
It's you develop
social relations.
For others the value can
just be pure entertainment,
and I think that's OK.
But as long as you are artful
and intentional about it
and you feel that
you're in control of it,
I think that's what
well-being looks like.
MAGGIE JACKSON: That's great.
Do you have any flourishing?
What does it look like?
ADAM ALTER: Yeah.
No, I think it's interesting,
because science generally
resists subjectivity.
You want a test.
You can give people a test.
There are 12 items.
You answer them.
You add up the score, and
you can say your well-being
level is average.
MAGGIE JACKSON: 4.2?
ADAM ALTER: You're a 4.2.
Yeah, exactly.
And I think that
what's been interesting
for me in studying
this topic for a while
is that people have a really
good sense subjectively, when
they introspect about how they
feel about their relationship
to technology.
And they're all using very
different metrics as Glen said.
So for some, it's about
social relationships
and facilitating that.
And that, for me, is a big part.
I live, as I imagine
you do, a long way
from a big part of my family.
And so technology has allowed
me to connect with them in a way
that is very, very enriching.
So that for me is a key factor.
For other people, that might
not be a factor at all.
Either you live near the people
that really matter to you,
or it's more important to you
to create, or to automatize,
or whatever it may be.
And so I think there
is no one definition.
And I think it'll be very hard
to find just one definition.
But I think the best
thing we can all do
is have a list of
questions to ask ourselves.
And the answers
to that, I think,
will illuminate for
each of us individually,
whether we've got a high or low
level of digital well-being.
And often for me,
digital well-being
comes from augmenting our
real non-digital experiences.
That's much of it for me.
So I like social connection.
I get more of that social
connection and better
social connection with people
I couldn't have it with,
using digital tools.
I want to know where I am.
I can do it better
with a map on a device.
All of that, I think, is
a really big part of it.
MAGGIE JACKSON: Right.
And there will be trade-offs.
In New York City, it
used to be that you'd
turn to someone on the
street and say, where am I?
And I'm very
directionally challenged.
Sometimes I'm even
math challenged.
So I turn to human beings.
And they look at me
as though I'm crazy.
Where's your phone?
They really look, and they
don't know where they are.
They have no idea
where they are.
So there are really good--
there are so many trade-offs.
It'll keep us guessing
for a long, long time.
Well, I think that I had
an interesting situation
with a friend that I'm
still trying to figure out,
where I sent him an article,
but instead of answering
that he had gotten it--
it was something very
close to my heart--
an article I had written about
tolerance in today's culture.
But he waited, and
waited, and waited.
And he was naturally going
to read it and then get back
to me.
But I felt like, wow, can't
you just say you got it?
And so it was really--
I just throw that out there.
There are no answers.
But I think that
acknowledgement,
communications-- maybe
this will keep us all--
it should keep us on our toes
in a better and better way.
GLEN MURPHY: I think that
exact case was something
that we saw in our own research
that was deeply surprising.
Going back to the discussion of
technology being a social tool,
I think one of the
aspects of it that we
found really surprising
was expectations
of how we use it with each
other haven't really been set.
I think with
telephones, we kind of
created a culture, like
don't call after this time,
because we're probably asleep.
It's going to ring in the house.
I feel that-- and
we saw this that--
we saw many of those
situations where
someone would send a message,
and they would not get a reply,
and they didn't know
what that meant.
They didn't know if the other
person was hurt or hated them.
We saw someone who-- it took her
three hours to get back to her
friend--
some amount of time,
because she was busy.
And when they finally
got in contact,
the friend was very upset
that it had taken three hours
to get back to someone.
And I feel like that is a sign
that we haven't developed quite
that shared understanding of
what use of these communication
technologies really means.
And I feel that
because we haven't
set that, we often
pressure ourselves
into being polite about it--
say, oh, if someone
sent me a message,
I have to respond right now,
because otherwise, they'll
worry.
And that social dynamic and
that cultural dynamic, I think,
is really interesting for us.
And so I think that's
something that we're
going to spend a lot
of time thinking about
and how we can help
through technology, nudge
things in the right direction.
ADAM ALTER: I think with
letters and emails--
so with letters, you only
got a certain number.
But emails-- some people
get hundreds a day.
And so we've tried
to apply the grammar
that we use to determine how
to deal socially with letters,
which is you always reply.
It's the polite thing to
do to email or to text.
And that doesn't work if
you get a certain number.
GLEN MURPHY: That's right.
ADAM ALTER: You get inundated.
And I was having this discussion
with my wife recently.
If I get, say, 100
emails a day and I
don't respond to one of them,
I make an active decision not
to reply, that
seems really rude.
But also, I didn't
invite conversation
with everyone who's emailing,
so you just never know
where to draw the line.
GLEN MURPHY: That's right.
Yeah.
ADAM ALTER: It's really tricky.
And I don't even
know if there is
a set of rules you
could draw up that would
allow you to deal with that.
GLEN MURPHY: No, especially for
the different types of people
that are emailing you--
work emails versus
emails from your parents,
different expectations, but
your habits may be the same.
MAGGIE JACKSON:
Different generations
have different
expectations, certainly.
But I think that maybe
we have to welcome
that type of uncertainty.
We'll keep working at it,
because it took a thousand
years for the book
to be hammered out
as the technology we know today.
In Shakespeare's time, there
were 150 different versions
of "Twelfth Night,"
and you could
buy all sorts of different plot
lines in London's bookstores.
In our remaining minutes, let's
try to look ahead, perhaps.
We've guessed a little
bit about, perhaps,
what digital
well-being might be.
But what's exciting?
What's coming up
in the pipeline,
either as a sort of
throwing our minds forward
to the future in terms
of technological digital
well-being?
Or what's really
exciting now for you?
Adam?
ADAM ALTER: I'm excited that
there's a conversation now
at this level.
The fact that I was
invited to speak here
is very exciting for me,
because I've been thinking
about these issues for a while.
And I used to spend the first
10 minutes of any conversation,
or any talk, convincing
people that this was something
we should even be discussing.
And we don't have
to do that anymore.
I think that's a
really good first step,
that when you look
people in the eye,
we all recognize that
this is something
we should be focusing on.
And that goes all the way up
to a big company like Google
and all the way down
to individual people
that you meet on the street.
So I think that's very exciting.
And then the question is
where we go from here.
And I think we're
really at the beginning.
And I wish there were better
scientific research out there
that suggested this is
what the damage will be.
This is what we need to change.
If we don't, this
is what'll happen,
and this is how we deal with it.
And it turns out, I'm at a very
exciting point, because I'm
doing some of this research.
But I think it's some of
the earliest research.
There isn't a huge
amount out there now.
So we're at the bottom of a
very tall, steep mountain,
and we will learn a
lot along the way.
But not much has been done.
There's a huge amount
of low-hanging fruit.
And that's what I'll be doing
with the next few years is
trying to work out, what should
we be really concerned about?
What are we just talking about?
Because there is
some degree of panic.
And then, how do
we deal with it?
How do we fix it, not just
as individual consumers who
are managing our own
use or our kids' use,
but also, how do
companies like Google
introduce new options,
new technologies?
And obviously, that's
already starting in a very--
I think encouraging way.
GLEN MURPHY: I think what I'm
sort of excited about is I
and I think many people here--
the reason why we
work in this space
is that we want to build
experiences that people love.
I think just delivering
something to someone
and seeing the joy
on their face--
I think that's a deeply
motivating factor for me
and I'm sure many of you.
And I feel like part
of this discussion
is an understanding
that we don't quite
know yet what it means for
people to love software.
I think, historically, we've
sort of measured that very
closely in terms of, oh, if
people are spending more time
using the thing that
I've built, clearly that
must mean that they love it.
And I feel like
this whole space is
about understanding that
that's not necessarily true.
And so what I'm
really excited about
is finding more of the evidence
that you talk about and more
of those tools and means, so
that we can all go and build
more lovable software.
MAGGIE JACKSON: That's great.
And I, too, would
second the idea
that it's so exciting, having
been in the space of writing
about technology for nearly
20 years now as a humanist,
to see the maturation of
discussion and the unease.
I think that's really
important, too.
I would say that--
and just to throw out--
I think that it's a
little bit different,
but it's part of well-being--
this issue of tolerance.
And I have seen some
very early evidence
that in this space
of the digital world,
more can be done
than one would think,
to kind of push back on the
hatred that's out there online.
There is a professor at
NYU, actually a PhD student,
who's done some amazing
work in the space of helping
people speak up.
And on Twitter,
he's found that when
there's a hater,
someone who's really
espousing horrific
things online and then
a person from their in-group.
So if there's a
white male espousing
hatred and a white male
who's influential--
has followers on Twitter--
makes one comment about,
hey, man, think again,
or these people are human.
What are you doing?
One comment lowers dramatically
the amount of hatred
from that person for two months.
And that's really
a remarkable thing.
So it speaks to a lot
of research right now.
There's an exciting
research on prejudice on
and offline on
combating prejudice,
that shows little points of
speaking up are important.
So technology that could
help us learn that,
or help us speak
up, or understand
when we're needed to say
something in the realm,
I think, is really important.
Another study out
of Europe showed
that if people are given
a kind of adventure game
and perspective, taking a
day in the life of Roma--
a person who's a Roma--
and the kinds of troubles
that they go through--
very short game has
extraordinary effects.
It lowers their likelihood to
vote for a far-right party.
It lowers their prejudice
against the Roma.
It also, for up to a year,
lowers their prejudice
against other minorities,
or other pariah people,
like people with a lot
of negative sentiment
about-- like refugees.
So I think these ripple
effects are really
important to tap in
the virtual world.
Ripple effects are there,
and that's really important.
So I think we've
covered a lot of ground.
But I hope we've raised some
good questions, something
to take away, to think
about, to chew over.
And I'll just say, to wrap
up, that we've certainly come
a long way from the days
of lantern slide shows
and the telegraph as the
state-of-the-art communications
tool.
And yet, we're still wrestling
with the tensions and promises
of technology.
All of what we're facing demands
creative spirits, open minds,
and a lot of questioning.
And questioning is the
opposite of complacency.
And unease is really a central
route to progress in a society.
So I think we have reason to be
optimistic that with your help,
we can create a more
healthy digital world.
Thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]